Speaker 1: Let's now go to George Anthony
devoted there.
Santos George Santos.
The lying of lying congressman who was arrested
yesterday on 13 criminal counts, held a manic,
unhinged press conference after being arrested.
It's wacky.
We're going to look at it.
It's just really, really wacky stuff.
And he is trying to do the Trump thing where
he says it's a witch hunt and it's all unfair
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He gives this event in Islip, New York.
Which borough is the guy, if you're watching
in the blue checkered suit over Santos's right
shoulder?
He's increasingly a corrosive actor in Republican
politics there in Long Island.
Let's listen to what Santos had to say.
And this is this is crazy.
I'm warning you, this is bonkers stuff.
Speaker 5: You guys, look, this is the beginning
of the ability for me to address and defend
myself.
We have an indictment.
We have all we have the information that the
government wants to come after me on.
I'm not even going to comply.
I've been complying throughout this entire
process.
I have no desire not to comply at this point.
They've been gracious in there.
Now I'm going to have to go and fight to defend
myself.
The reality is, is it's a witch hunt because
it makes no sense that in four months, four
months, five months, I've indicted you have
Joe Biden's entire family receiving deposits
from the.
Speaker 1: Crowd, not reacting positively
to that.
Speaker 5: Nine family members receiving money
from foreign from foreign destinations into
their bank accounts.
It's been years of exposing.
A lot of you here have reported on them, and
yet no investigation is launched into them.
I'm going to fight.
I will.
And I'm just glad I'm getting back that I'm
going to fight my battle.
I'm going to deliver.
Speaker 1: All right.
So it's a witch hunt, he says.
Asked whether he will resign, he says that
he will not.
Speaker 5: Congressman.
Speaker 2: And you will not resign?
Speaker 1: I will not resign, Congressman.
I will not resign.
Now, he may be kicked out.
One interesting thing that happened in the
last 24 hours is that Kevin McCarthy, the
Republican speaker of the House, said, I do
not support the reelection of George Santos.
Now, you might say, who cares if Kevin McCarthy
doesn't support it?
In general, Republican leadership supports
the reelection of Republicans who are running
for reelection.
So this could be the beginning of Republicans
actually saying we've got to we've got to
do something about this.
Hilariously, he was he Jorge Santos was asked,
why did you apply for unemployment benefits
when you were making 120 grand a year working?
And of course, this is one of the different
frauds that he's alleged to have committed.
And he says, well, that this is all going
to be part of my defense.
Speaker 5: In an orderly fashion.
Speaker 2: Why would you apply for unemployment
benefits when you had a job making $120,000
a year?
Speaker 1: By the way, I have four people
who are watching.
There's about 80 who are not watching.
There's about 80 microphones in front of him.
It almost looks satirical.
And there's a guy in the back holding a sign
that says Devil Dare defraud the voters, which
is just a beautiful touch.
It's this SNL can't do anything with this
because it wouldn't look any different to
parody this event.
Speaker 5: This is part of my defense, accurate
information, and I will get to clear my name
on this during the pandemic.
It wasn't very clear.
I don't understand where the government's
getting their information, but I will protect
my prosecutor.
Speaker 2: Say that you got over $20,000 in
unemployment baggage, sir.
How is that acceptable, ma'am?
Speaker 5: Like I said, my employment was
changed during the time.
I don't understand where the government is
coming from.
Speaker 1: My and he's all totally confused.
At another moment, he completely delusionally
says that in a couple of years he'll be chairman
of a committee in the House.
Now, listen, he may or may not make it out
of the next month.
I don't know.
It depends on what Republicans are going to
do.
The idea that he's going to get reelected
and subsequently become the chair of a committee
really is a level of delusion that raises
a lot of red.
Speaker 2: Flags for yourself, for so many.
Speaker 5: Well, look, I the way I look at
it, I'll be a chairman of a committee in a
couple of years.
If you just look at the standard of Congress,
look at the Senate.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Soon.
This is no worse than anything everybody else
is doing in the House and Senate.
So he'll be chairman of a committee trying
to put sort of a positive spin on this entire
thing.
He says he's feeling fine despite 13 criminal
charges.
Speaker 5: I'm feeling.
Look, it's hard.
Look, look, I'm addressing I'm addressing
one of your colleagues here.
I don't want to give the back of you.
So, as usual, I do my best to be a positive
person.
Why?
This is already as bad as it gets.
It can be.
So I. I'm fine.
Speaker 1: And somebody yelling, his lips
are moving.
Therefore, he must be lying, is the implication.
Okay, he.
This is maybe the funniest moment.
He starts talking about getting back to Washington,
D.C. to vote on like a border bill.
He's pretending to be a normal congressman.
And there's something so funny like, yes,
members of Congress vote on bills.
But the idea that this guy is going to now
be able to just pretend to be a normal congressman
with 13 criminal counts against him is a joke.
Speaker 2: In Washington.
Speaker 5: Now.
Yes, I am.
I have to go back and vote tomorrow.
We have one of those consequential votes in
this Congress, which is a border bill.
And I'm very looking forward to being there
to vote on it.
Speaker 1: All right.
He's going to pretend to be a normal congressman.
And then lastly, FOX News caught up with De
Santos, with Santos, his lawyer, on the way
out.
The lawyer was mostly interested in finding
his car, but he did say, I don't really have
anything to do with Santos choosing to hold
that wacky press conference.
Speaker 2: He didn't have too much that you
wanted to share at this time.
He just talked to himself.
What do you have to say about how your client
is feeling right now?
Speaker 4: Oh, my God.
Speaker 2: It's looking for his car.
But hold on with us, Martha.
I mean, he had a lot to say in that press
conference, but that's up to him.
Okay.
I know you said didn't want to try it in the
media, but how is he feeling?
He looked a little nervous when he was in
court today.
A lot of serious allegations.
Speaker 4: How many times have you been arrested?
Speaker 1: All right.
So making the point that people just get nervous
when they get arrested, but that it's really
up to Santos whether he holds these press
conferences.
So a completely manic, wacky event.
It's taking on a sort of circus sideshow feel.
And it seems as though Santos can't get away
from circus sideshows.
We're going to see it.
We'll see if this guy survives the next month.
I hope he doesn't, but I don't have a prediction
right now.